there is a new sex survey out and yeah
you are a sexual deviant you freak
that's right there is a lot of stuff
going on here the Journal of Sexual
Medicine published some interesting
findings and we've got some of them for
you right here so researchers from the
University of Montreal presented 799 men
and 718 women I'm always curious where
they come up with those numbers 85% of
whom identified as heterosexual 4%
homosexual and 11% somewhere in-between
so there's a lot of by people I guess
with a long list of statements regarding
fantasy scenarios asking them to rate
their agreement with each on a scale of
one to seven anything rated over three
was counted as a fantasy and let's look
at the results
okay so men are in green females are in
blue pretty much equal on the group sex
everybody's sort of feeling group sex
equally not a ton of people are into it
but everyone kind of likes it females
now in a certain spot yeah we had a
little debate I don't even know what
that means that means okay not a certain
spot of the body they say do you like
having sex in a certain spot or were
they like do you like having sex you
know on the couch or did they men well
in here I actually have an answer for
you because they did ask them they
wanted to open was a specific location
they didn't ask them which location it
was whether it was an airport or
something of that nature but they just
where they want to have in a specific
spot let's look back with the stranger
so females want to have sex with the
stranger so we're just gonna plow
through this no pun intended and here's
the fascinating one males a lot of males
are fantasizing about having anal not
just having it receive what seeming anal
men to pay attention to currently
because this graph here because this
just shows that men think that anal sex
is a good thing to have so I would just
like to show that based on that small
chunk of blue women don't agree
don't usually agree you know you're
giving us a real interesting view into
your sex life and finally as far as
receiving oral sex men do think about
that a lot they also think about it you
know but they do think about receiving
or a lot women think about receiving
oral less okay
so there's some interesting stuff there
does anything I guess the anal sex thing
the men receiving anal sex that seems to
be the one that's surprising us is that
the one that's the big one out of it
I mean I'm personally not really
surprised that my occupations I've had
to do this but um no yeah I think that I
have had that no yeah I mean I don't
know if it's it's surprising I I want to
see like the other really really
surprising like was there anything on
there that was like real shocking I
looked over at SIGGRAPH and I wanted to
see if there was like huge discrepancies
between like men and women on things and
there was nothing like super surprising
I feel like everybody's kind of right
did you think I mean the the sex with a
stranger part was just a what do you
make of that so yeah okay it makes me
seem like this like one of those staunch
Bay Area lesbians night I mean I feel
like maybe they're like fantasizing
about having sex with people that are
not their husbands that are satisfying
them okay so I mean I don't even know
that that's a lesbian theory I think
that's just pretty
theory I just feel like you will blame
it on the fact that I'm when they hear
it's the stranger it's a thing like I
can get it like maybe if you're in a
relationship you're fantasizing about
you know Joe Smith from work or like X
celebrity you know but to say like a
stranger that's just a little bit like
because you're creating like somebody
that's like really like fulfilling all
of your fantasies is this thing just
basically a sort of condemnation of
straight men that's what it seems to be
right because straight men are very
afraid of doing anything with their body
that's that's one thing and this thing
about the women wanting a second
strategy it's sort of like because there
is just straight guys are just kind of
boring and I'm gonna get a lot of hate
into you in the comment section I know
it's coming but that women are just like
looking at the guy that they're with and
they're like this guy is so boring and
so out of shape and so but that I would
like to censor the perfect stranger that
would do it more more than even just
fantasy about the guy that I was people
need to look at this and have an open
conversation about the fact that maybe
women just need to start having anal sex
with men that is the top Mexican
satisfying all the way around men will
be happy women will probably be happy
because they're getting something out of
it finally whether it be like a power
struggle yeah you know Jacqueline
Madeline want to have sex in those in a
bizarre place is there a place I mean
sure that sounds like I mean like I'm
open to certain things jive with what
your thought I mean some of it but like
the stranger thing does not does not
sound like fun to me no stranger is
really just people when they ask that if
people are just thinking someone other
than my significant other that I'm with
and an Internet setting that makes more
sense right but it did say stranger so I
I mean honestly like I like this whole
article because like I feel like people
are so scared to talk about sex you know
like they're so uptight about it and
especially like even the women and stuff
that they were interviewing you know
giving these answers and stuff and you
know even though I personally don't you
know drive with the whole stranger thing
like if that's something that you know
turns on other women good for you talk
about it be open about it don't be
afraid don't be afraid of what people
are gonna call you or if people are
going to judge you you know like be open
about people are so afraid to talk about
sex
I agree don't we need more I mean even
this little four-minute discussion that
were having don't we need more of this
on TV like you see all these people I
always think this when I'm watching like
election coverage last night I know
you're watching like these 20 people
that you know all their political
opinions but like at the end of the day
goes but if I like at the end of the day
this wolf blitzer want to be tied up and
peed on you're like that would vote more
clearly I would vote you know with more
faith if I knew their sexual practices
listen to their political opinions if I
knew that Paul Begala wants
something good here ah
we both went to PE politicians have been
interested in what goes on in the
bedroom for a long time so about time we
start talking about it now final thought
on this have you ever encountered anyone
that wanted to do something really
freaky sexual that you it just blew your
mind you were like I can't be part of
this oh you've got something I mean I I
may or may not have briefly dated
someone who was far more interested in
my feet than I would have liked a little
strange but uh that ended very quickly
so it's okay